[Music]
guys it was just over a month ago we
gave you the best of dust - and surprise
surprise it turns out there are a hell
of a lot of God to your plays that took
place on that hallowed ground after all
I've said it before and I'll say it
again guys - called us to a staple and
counter-strike would be one hell of an
understatement and when we produced that
video it sparked a heated debate in the
office amongst the counter-strike heads
as to what the ultimate dust2 moment
really was so we figured hell why not
rank them all and give you a top ten so
without further ado I present you with
the top 10 greatest moments on dust2 in
csgo kicking off our list at number 10
is this ridiculous melange of panic and
style from Team M biases and BK after
running out of ammo in the first round
of ESL one cologne 2015's grand final
the Frenchman shows flusher that
sometimes bringing a knife to a gunfight
is a viable strategy
[Music]
Jewelry children
double kill an enemy they take the
pistol was pandemonium and look at this
moment PO flares running out of ammo on
the platform and MBK taking the knife
that amazing stuff and what a brilliant
start at the number nine spot is a
clutch played out to absolute perfection
at ESO pro league season three's grand
final seriously just sit back and watch
in awe as g2 shocks plays this clutch
against luminosity gaming like it was
just another day at the office it's all
short [ __ ] of one or three to try and
keep it alive otherwise we'll go to a
fifth map in the grand finals sharks
tabs out one that's a deadly kill goes
for the second and he's moving closer
looking for the quad watch it for next
to last met alive he's gonna stab the
bottom watch what is this that is silly
I'm wondering why fallen the bomb is
planted for four platform out long I
figured fallen would've just stayed out
there at the eighth place on our list is
perhaps one of these scariest things you
can see if you're playing CT side on
dust2 at ESL one cologne 2015's grand
finals match fanatics overtime economy
was so large they decided to close out
the half with the bang or four and look
at the guns
aw Peas they're ready to shoot some
ducks as they cross the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and
not in this lifetime he is destroyed
well when they're lining up like that
you know you're in trouble JW already
inside our number seven place shows us
that anyone can make a big impact on an
eco round with a little luck and a lot
of guts armed with nothing but a p250 to
start off pip goes on an absolute tear
against g2 esports stealing an a k to
single-handedly take the round for his
team hit the last man standing is
jumping P 250 Cardiff it must be done
after Baba's walk and now he's got
position here
it's God like that was a fantastic play
the ace out of knowing Kevlar this guy
that's what that's what a knife he
needed the number six spot on our list
goes to this lightning-fast clutch from
ni PS get right at ESL one Katowice a
2015's quarterfinals the last round of
the half seas the Swedish legend pull
off a timely clutch with just 20 points
of health and 15 seconds left on the
clock file this one under just get right
things get right try to all no 1v2
running up here p250 out jumping and
shooting against one more kill looking
for these got any money down time is up
oh my god Wow okay just it's been it's
been so far it's just being individual
craziness from all of nit coming in at
number five on our list is Guardian who
shows the world how to take and hold a
site as a Teesside offer after deleting
JW guardian proceeds to stroll into B
and take out three fanatic members as he
dances around beep lat he can't play
peek-a-boo with Guardian bro another
near unwinnable position flash bang goes
10th Guardian leg Sam and wood gets the
1 killer Guardian he's trapped behind
the box he gets a shot he goes for moist
gonna hit it off this and now it's all
about cardio I guess oh my god he picks
up 4 kills and wins it ok then
come on Guardian get fired up boy there
we go that wakes the crowd up that gets
everything going taking the number 4
spot on our list is navi's edward who
pulls off a gutsy play for the ages at
2015's IEM San Jose on the other side
event don't make something of this you
know they're all three players are wait
to go down this is insane a trend they
get said would bomb planted spoke in
Edwards that bully goes out
[Applause]
beyond play I've seen enough presents
but you had to have known this one would
be on here he goes iconic in human
reactions takes the number three spot on
our list the shot and the words that
accompanied it have become one of the
most quotable moments in counterstrikes
storied history Kiko is gonna go for it
in Freiburg will eventually fall but it
is too late
Garen is gonna be waiting he co charges
in dozens he cold not even with an aim
but could you have got that kill and he
Co he stood in the one of three almost
unwinnable position but that is a
terrifying message to anyone who ever
dares to challenge he code our number
two spot shows off a stellar performance
of skill awareness and split-second
decision-making by ni Pease exists
staring down a 1v3 situation exists
plays the clutch to absolute perfection
all while making fools of luminosity
gaming exists doesn't have a whole lot
left to work with and also constantly
washing up for that flank here now at
the next he's gonna strike soon he's out
twelve eight we left unexist now with a
triple shot shuts it down exists might
be able to make that maybe could have
got to be just on the edge but this
could be smart or it could be over cold
Sarah's gonna get the peek now they know
his position 39 seconds he's 12 HP this
is so little to work with okay okay this
one's gonna hear steps here but yeah
here we go he's gonna get upon out of
this he's got a chance in this one now
now try to hold back however as the both
of the rain members of LG are gonna try
to go for a retake back to earth
smoking all fees in the corner that we
believe in what do we really need to say
about the number one pick for this list
you've seen the clip many times and it
still doesn't get old
hell maybe you've even tried to imitate
it on more than one occasion in your own
games that's right we're talking about
simples opt throw it's not just like
wait you know he's like what the [ __ ] is
gonna know now it's often debated just
how much of an effective thrown off had
as a distraction for nitro but it's
undeniable that this is one of the most
stylish and memorable plays in dust twos
lengthy history close range it's a one
shot nitro he's got a triple he fakes it
once and just goes to check the window
this is all about timing Nitro does have
the most often under smoke so it could
be really rough for simple times to get
through this he's gotta throw that test
you can't say that that's a fake well
guys that about wraps it up for the top
ten greatest moments on dust2 in csgo
now I probably shouldn't be telling you
this but we are working on the best of
new right now so if there's another map
you want to see us give the highlight or
the ranking treatment well let us know
in the comments section and we will try
to make it happen thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button